always surprised if anybody knows who
the hell I am oh they know who you are
when you're playing to thousands of
people you got your bass and I've got my
core but you know what I find though
like I find like they know who I am and
the second the show's over all I need to
do is get three blocks away from the
from the theater and nobody knows nobody
knows the same thing yeah but I like
that no I love it I like that I don't
want to be that guy that like I can't go
you know you see these people my
favorite celebrity thing ever is the
bowling alley in your house is the funny
you probably have one right now no I
don't okay good but like the bowling
alley in the house is like Jesus Christ
you can't go bowling right it's like
that like what kind of a it's like with
Elvis when we used to sit and talk I
could never get him out to dinner okay
can I just digest what you just said
it's like with Elvis when we used to sit
and talk can you please talk to me about
sitting and talking what year what year
was when I was at Caesar's Palace uh
when he started work in Vegas the
unicorns
but I knew him before because we were
with RCA Victor records you know there
was us this band of teenagers and then
there was Elvis this amazing looking guy
who had the its with a black voice and
we all looked at this guy right and
there was nobody like Elvis from our
menu of people I get to know him and
then I really get to know him in Vegas
when he started working in Vegas when
the colonel signed him up at the Hilton
and I would go over and hang with them
and it was a hang you know you'd walk in
a room all the windows had aluminum foil
on it aluminum foil why
didn't want any daylight oh okay yeah
you didn't know where people just go
with drapes not good enough not
eccentric enough yeah we're going to get
a drape out of a drawer right and get
the aluminum foil so and they love the
guns you know he's shooting The Gunshot
up the TV set but the point that I was
going to make is wait we shot a gun in
the hotel no he didn't like Robert
Goulet
Robert Goulet came on television he was
a guy from Canada for some whatever the
hard-on he had for him and he came on
television he shot the TV he said I said
thank God for my way I'm going to get
out of here alive right because he was a
minor what's that Jordan thing he
probably he probably took exception
somehow the Robert Goulet let me ask you
you said something interesting we said
he had like the black voice and
everything yeah did you ever talk to him
about how
um
the perception that people had like
like you know he was doing black music
and he was getting the credit and the
the black artists weren't and all of
that type of stuff which was a thing
because of the level of racism and all
of that but then like now like 70 years
later it's almost like they look at him
like he wasn't even talented where it's
like you got to be all right you got to
dial that
this like there's a whole bunch of like
when I look at Elvis it's like I
understand all of that other stuff but
that um
he was sort of the blueprint I feel like
of the rock star where like every cliche
thing that a rock star can get involved
in like there was no information for him
where the hangers on people giving you
drugs like like literally everything you
know uh music changing right somebody
else coming in and like and there was
like nobody I feel like he could really
sit down and talk to
like when you hit did you hit like he
came he he hit what 55 or 50 years at 55
I hit in 56 and he hit about a year
before I did so when you were watching
him like and then he goes into the army
and then when he comes back the Beatles
are out right watching him navigating
that yeah and getting talked into doing
the movies and stuff and the Sinatra
special and all that yeah now were you
and Bobby Darin sitting there going like
like
watching that going okay
I do this or I wouldn't do that
um or were you guys too close in age
when stuff was moving too fast for you
to contemplate that we were focusing on
the foundation we had and what we had to
do Elvis had his own Vibe we all knew
that we all knew the colonel couldn't
leave the country great Carney guy did
you know that back then that he couldn't
leave the country because the word was
out you know everybody knew everything
you ever remember pop music back then
was in his infancy stage there's no
Hendricks yet there's no Beatles yet
right you know I I was somewhat
responsible for the Beatles coming here
because I was living over in England as
living in France and I would come home
in a society that wasn't media driven
right you know people don't fathom the
fact that it wasn't a media driven
Society then you knew nothing you know
today it's like wow instant nobody knew
what was going on so the point was I
would come home from England I meet the
Beatles In Paris their work in the
Olympia Theater where I started as a kid
taking pictures with drinking we're
meeting hey Paul we want to publish and
we want to write and all of this stuff
and I'm coming home telling Normie Weiss
a general artist Sid Bernstein who are
my agents I said man there's these kids
they got the hair and they're doing
these covers and they're looking at me I
mean what beetles and I'm telling you I
love them you know I love them as a
musician I said you've got to get over
there and sign them nobody knew they
were there
Fade Out fade in eventually they go over
in 64 and they bring the Beatles over
first shot on Ed Sullivan but till then
nobody knew they existed what were they
like what were they like when you were
hanging out with them did you I mean
there's no way you had any idea they
were going to be that big they were
different for me I'd never seen anything
like it but when you spoke with them and
you hung they still had that quirky
little Edge you know they always tried
to be like comedians they'd always have
something off points and make a little
humor out of it they were very much that
way but still you could see they were
trying to find their Niche because it
didn't happen you know in our business
until you put the mileage in
you know we know we all have to sweat it
out you're not there yet you know it
took Elton 2 000 miles it took everybody
some mileage to get to where they're at
same with them they were just a cover
band but when you saw them
you knew there was something going on
and then the vibe started in Great
Britain the point I was making is till
them
Elvis was criticized
my group criticized anything indigenous
to pop music the fans loved us but the
adults didn't like us
most of us were widifying rock and roll
we were clergyman's answer because it
was all the black experience that I
loved and lived on I could barely get
them on the radio and you know I toured
down south I come out of Canada
and I'm touring down this up and I got
all my black brothers who guys I
idolized Chuck Berry uh Lyman Fats
Domino I'm on a bus all of a sudden
going through the South where they're
not allowed in to eat
and I said [__] I ain't going in well
you guys now I'm a kid I'm starting to
compute this I said I ain't going in
I'll go get the food and bring it well
we can't go to the bathroom well let's
go five miles an hour you open the door
and you're pissing out outside of the
bus
I'd never seen anything like it White's
over here blacks over here cops dogs and
I'm with my brothers people that I
idolized as a kid couldn't do this you
couldn't do that boy what an Awakening
that was for me to see before the Civil
Rights